so these are YouTube Pranksters
another dancing you're not a den Yeah
well yeah yeah that's good right yeah
yeah
oh oh oh oh oh oh yo don't do that buddy
yo wait why did you hit me hey Bobby you
hit me I didn't hit you I just shot on
your head oh oh
oh whoa oh
wait oh yo you got to chase him oh oh
he said go outside
where are
you cushion man you already had the
discussion and I already talked about
how Prince that [__] was and how and how
that [__] made me feel we already he had
his head on
huh he has his head on I mean he took it
took it again he took it he took it
again I already told you how I felt
about [__] like that you understand what
I'm saying like we already had this this
you know you know when you cringe
yo oh my day he didn't ask for nothing
he's getting oh my God bro sometimes I
go on Facebook right
and I haven't been in a while I go and
then there's some videos that are
suggested to me and it's all these
things like these things like that where
they go like oh oh a staring at gangster
is the wrong way uh it's oh I can't
watch that [__] there was some prankster
that got some people that did pranks
like that that actually got got shot
they ended up dead you [__] around and
you find out
yo yo yo relax dude oh relaxed
look I got 30 people outside the video
bro what's this the video
it was just a video you know what you're
doing bro yeah
yo it's a video oh now you got a problem
now you got a problem now you don't want
you want him you was all up in his face
taking this capping [__] now you're like
yeah back up at nah B that's not how
this [__] works out
that is not how this [__] works now
you're like yo back up be back cause
you're two [__] right and he's
alone
so now you go you're puffing up your
[__] this is not how this works now you
want him to back up after you antagonize
the man you want him to back up
I hope I hope this finishes with both of
you getting [__] in the mouth because
that's what you deserve there's a video
look it's a video oh oh
[__] you up
you a [__] you a [__] you a hoe
that's what you all of that
you are a whole ass [__]
yeah yeah you're gonna antagonize people
and when they get mad you got a
[__] mace you a hoe you a
[__] hoe
um
[Applause]
oh my babe
he kicked him while he was walking away
in case it wasn't bro you said you were
gonna violate him and you kicked him
while he was walking away oh [__]
now y'all running
you a [__]
you a [__] you could get this beating
you a [__] Loki like you know when the
whole thing with Kai happen you know we
had the first initial video where we
talked about the silly prank where he
was [__] around with people nothing
on this level it's not even close but
then after that you know we did a
subsequent video where I think where he
won you know the biggest streamer award
or whatever the [__] it was you recent
big milestone I congratulated him I
thought it was a beautiful moment
maybe he's a generational thing
but I like this like yo this whole
generation of like pranking people real
life and [__] with people at their
jobs and putting on camera and making
money off of them and trying to make
them look like clowns to your fans I
don't know it's a bit weird like if it's
one thing if you want to clown somebody
when they put up your own content they
say some Goofy and you want okay people
are just working at their jobs you go
and film them without their consent you
[__] around with them not knowing what
kind of stress they're going through and
you put that up for money and not only
that you escalate the [__] where you
kick him
I hope they jail your ass I hope if they
if this man don't catch you by the end
of this video I hope they jail your
[__] ass
[Music]
YouTuber Nas ebk charged with making
terroristic threats
after he appeared to pull a knife on a
stranger and a prank gone wrong so he's
in prison for that that is on February
24th all right another update Bronx
rapper Nas ebk arrested for
second-degree murder one week ago now if
the murder charges turn out to be true
when everything I've seen from this kid
I'll be rots in jail
um I already hate his guts good I know
everyone is watching right now stop
[__] with people they on the job you
want to go there and make their life
hard for no reason I hope you get decked
in the face too I'm not saying he's the
right thing but I hope it happens to you
there's too many people out here want to
get up in people's faces say all kinds
of crazy stuff I hope you get punched in
the face I don't know who raise some of
you [__] animals the weird stuff
you'll be doing to going up in people's
faces taking their clothes off like
rough growing up you couldn't even scuff
a man's air forces without a fight
breaking up taking off a nigga's head
and treating him like a clown
y'all are weird
I don't understand it I don't understand
it I see I think I understand why I just
could never understand wanting to get
clout that badly that you would
[__] with people like that that's what I
don't understand
you can pay me enough money to do some
goofy [__] like this I highly recommend
you try to remove someone's a hat in
prison
Oh my days tell them it's just a prank
and see how long your butthole stays the
same size
try that [__]
try that [__] yo it's hot y'all are
brave when you think somebody's helpless
[__] cornballs bro go ahead it's it's
hard man yeah
it's hard like it's a different song it
was really different type of like come
on give him your old [__] speech give
him that old [__] speech
I really don't want to be that dude you
want to see this hair
there's white hair in it you understand
what I'm saying
like I'm gonna be 41 this year you
understand what the [__] I'm saying 20
years ago the age of some of you
[__] I remember what the hell I
was doing when I was born now that being
said I remember there was a time
you could never
you could you never because that owner
of that person or that person working at
that store knew someone that knew you
and had a gang and it was a phone number
that was really quick and [__]
would have come down on you and find you
why and why I'm saying this because I've
seen it happen you do some [__] you
clown a girl or you clown one girl
and big brother comes in
with the cousins
in the car and when they get out of that
beach it looks like a whole outfit
circus coming out of the clown they in a
[__] BMW e35 and it's 35 [__] in
that [__] coming out to whoop your ass
you could never I've seen guys just
Clowning girls or cat calling girls not
but 30 minutes after that oh hell broke
loose I've seen the wrath of angry
[__] towards their family
members of other people and they did not
do half of what you're doing half you
kick a [__] that's going
there was consequence and it was not
clout and it was not comments the
consequences were physical like Abba
said I don't know who raised you animals
but at that age
I could never
because no no not only would I get a
beating from the people that are
offending and I wasting the time but
when I got home if my mama ever heard I
did some dumbass [__] like that oh oh
and both my parents was in my in my in
my household so you know damn well they
would have passed that belt like past
that Dutch Missy Elliott you understand
I could never
I do not know what the [__] it is going
on or what the hell you think is funny
in that but people work hard for the
[__] money rent is high bill is
high and that's what you decide to do a
day job take the hats and stuff like
that and when they tell you to get the
[__] out you stand like you own the I
never wanna wish bad things on people I
do but if something bad happens to you I
do no sympathy from me none none none if
whatever happens to you happens to you
hey I'm not gonna lie to you in
situations like these I put on my best
Avatar [__] face painting and I'm a
Buddhist monk cause I wanna believe in
some Karma and I think we got it and it
ain't a dish from an Indian store it's
that good old-fashioned payback yes sir
you going to jail now
yeah
yeah let's uh some making some
memory I hope your ass rots in jail
there you go go oh happy you don't
believe no [__] them [__] them yeah you
need to learn that [__] [__] it you need
to learn yeah you need to more of these
[__] goober ass pranksters need to go
to jail so that young folks watching
this [__] on Tick Tock don't think [__]
this [__] is all sweet yeah go to jail I
hope they make an example out of them I
did an extra penalty back in my days are
only disturbing the pieces that we knew
was ludicrous bro they they assaulted
this dude at his job and turned it into
content they uploaded that video yo yo
send them to the Galaxy and I really
wish that whenever they whenever
whenever they go for uh they go for your
ass whenever you're gonna be in court
the other lawyer pulls that video out
yeah or if you yeah this is [__]
that you want free no that's what he
does in this is what he does in his free
time yeah I wish D I wish they'd do that
if I was on that journey and they pulled
that video you gone and I wish that
lawyer is gonna go oh that's him oh we
got ourselves and they pulled that [__]
on you you know why because you loaded
it stupid yeah bro bro
we can move on from this because yeah we
done with this thank you very much
I'm Petty
I'll find out where your parents live
drive by Blood you could have been home
but you were in jail stupid
I'll enjoy this one I'm gonna enjoy it
justice that Justice good I'm glad yes
go to jail stupid
enjoy